it seems to me that no matter who you
are or where you're from if you train
you probably get inspired by dragon ball
even the seemingly most unlikely people
at your gym can probably hum falconer's
vegeta theme
or perform the fusion dance but just how
useful is the kind of training depicted
in the anime and manga
and how do you really go about getting a
body that looks and performs like goku
or vegeta's
and if you're interested in improving
martial arts performance as well as
strength
then how should you train
when i think of dragon ball training i
tend to think of those scenes where
they're training
in high gravity using really intense
high repetitions
of bodyweight movements and this
actually makes a ton of sense for
martial artists
for all sorts of reasons which we're
going to discuss in a moment
the other type of training often see
them doing is more of your kind of
old-school kung fu movie which is
probably
toriyama's influences showing the kind
of thing you get in rocky films where
they're
chasing monkeys around planets or
performing tasks and
training as a kind of byproduct of that
sort of thing and these again
kind of make sense vegeta's version of
that is going to a
abandoned planet and screaming into a
meteor storm he's a little bit more
hardcore
the same kind of thing applies this is
training that doesn't necessarily look
like
training combining these things makes a
ton of sense
for a martial artist and i'm going to
describe how you can
adapt that to your own training in a way
that doesn't necessarily involve
you know extreme gravity or tiny round
planets
the big question when it comes to
strength training and martial arts
though is whether you can be packed with
muscle and still move
powerfully explosively and fluidly there
is a common misconception that muscle
will slow you down
this is a view held by many excellent
martial artists
and of course we see this in dragon ball
z when trunks builds himself up to that
massive size
against cell but then is actually too
slow to be of any use
but the problem is not the muscle itself
in fact
muscles are what generate power every
time you punch
it comes from muscle by the way i am not
a bodybuilder who's also a great martial
artist i'm neither a
bodybuilder nor a martial artist i'm a
jack of all trades it shows in my
punches as anyone who
has seen the comments section on my
youtube will know
doing my best to get better grant's
giving me some tips but
yes this is not the focus of my training
take a look at someone like jean-claude
van damme
for the perfect example of someone who
is extremely muscular like goku
but who also has snappy powerful punches
or how about mike tyson
even jackie chan was pretty big at some
points in his career anon would accuse
him of being slow and stiff
jason's statham has been pretty bulky at
times too like i said the problem is not
the muscle itself the problem is
the order and the way in which you
coordinate the use of that muscle
and here's the issue with something like
powerlifting just doing
bench press and things because obviously
when you punch again this is an
approximation because i'm
not the best you have to twist your hips
and push through your shoulder
it's a full body movement a bench press
involves lying on your back
with your core rigid pushing a heavy
weight directly
upwards all you're using there is your
pecs your shoulders your triceps and arm
movement and the body is necessarily
rigid in fact it's deactivated
you build massive pecs because you're
able to isolate those muscles
and thereby put all the muscle damage
all the metabolic
build up all of the fatigue on them but
you can't then translate that so easily
into a puncture it's an entirely
different movement
and the issue here is neural maps
so you're repeating the same bench press
movement over and over again
where you learn that to generate power
you must go
like this push something straight
forwards with your body so then when you
put someone
like that in front of a punch bag what
do they do
they do the same thing they push
straight from the chest keeping their
torso rigid
instead of generating power
from the hips and from the core so
and this happened to me because for many
years that's how i primarily trained and
i'm trying to undo
some of that damage and become more
fluid once again
we see an example of this kind of
interference in swimmers one study
showed that swimmers were actually worse
at jumping
than the untrained population in other
words if you just sit on the couch all
day
you'll jump higher than a swimmer
because swimming makes you worse at
jumping
that of course is because you've
developed different neural maps and
strengthened different muscles
that's not to say that a swimmer can't
also become very good at other things
just look at a triathlete for instance
all it means is that the bench press on
its own
won't translate to a more powerful punch
in fact possibly the opposite
and so it's appropriate that we don't
typically see goku and vegeta lifting
weights
and it's funny that so many people who
are inspired by those guys then spend
all the time
in the gym doing exactly that so perhaps
you should ditch the resistance training
altogether why bother building muscle
simple
because resistance training applied
correctly can increase power as well as
giving you that goku physique
and martial arts looks much cooler when
you've got a ripped physique
or to put it another way bruce lee
trained with weights so so should you
specifically adding about 75 of your
body weight will allow you to train in
an explosive manner
while still encouraging greater fast
twitch fiber recruitment muscle damage
mechanical tension and all that good
stuff you get from resistance training
in other words we can develop power with
just the right amount of resistance
and i say 75 of body weight because this
won't be so much as to slow the movement
down to a grind
in one study it was found that sprinters
could get faster by training with a
heavy sled
however this was only effective when
pulling up to 75 percent of their body
weight
the key then is to apply this amount of
resistance in a movement pattern that
closely mimics the movements we want to
train
this is simply the law of specificity as
seen all across functional training
and this is exactly the kind of thing
good sports coaches will get their mma
fighters doing
so that's what we're trying to train
we're trying to train the strength and
the coordination
you can do this by training something
like a powerlifting routine
and then practicing your skill on top of
that but ultimately the two are going to
be somewhat working
against each other and it's not going to
be supporting you because you're not
building
the powerful obliques you're not
creating that
motor recruitment in those areas that
you need it to be and you're not
learning to use it all at once so
instead
you should use more functional training
tools and methods
that do involve torque in the waist and
the hips and that do involve standing
upright
jc santana described a bench press
as building these massive pecs that were
too powerful for your core
and saying that that was like trying to
fire a cannon from a canoe you might be
able to bench press 150 kilograms
but if you try and push anything close
to that standing up
you're going backwards so there's no
point on the other hand something like a
uh cable punch out or a wood chopper
anything like that
you're now bracing the core and you're
providing that pushing and that pulling
movement which allows you to utilize all
the muscles together
in the way they need to be you're adding
on just that little bit of extra
resistance
to make the movement more powerful more
coordinated instead of
trying to work against something that's
actually going to be slowing you down
another move you can use is a medicine
ball rotational throw
project the weight from your shoulder as
you torque the body just as you would
throw a punch
this is an even more ballistic movement
that lets you exert maximum power
if you want to move fluidly you need to
train fluidly
similar principles apply to other
movement patterns the bulgarian bag is a
fantastic tool for developing the kind
of torque and core strength
you need for grappling and even works
the grip and strength endurance
there are other similar movements you
can perform with a kettlebell too
another trope of dragon ball training is
weighted clothing and this is perfect
after all using weighted clothing in the
real world will typically add just the
right amount of resistance
we can then use explosive plyometric
movements that let us work on rate of
force development and explosiveness
with the added resistance to increase
those gains training explosively with
these movements is important whether or
not you choose to add weight
to begin with your own body weight may
be enough on its own to continue
building your strength reserves
just take a look at the conditioning
work grant does i've never seen anyone
punch with as much speed and power as
him
so yeah explosive calisthenics works
guys in terms of
i guess like conditioning or outside of
martial arts would probably be
some kind of push-up variation maybe
like a jack push-up
i quite like those they're very
explosive it's where you kind of like go
down into a push-up and your legs shoot
out at the same time
then come back in as you come up it
works a lot of your body it's really
good for your core
it kind of forces you to hold yourself
into that position very sturdily as you
go down
and you can add that onto like a burpee
or something as well so i do like those
all of these movements where you're kind
of like moving from the ground into the
air quickly with a jump because like i
said before it kind of mimics the
movements of martial arts to a degree
and it's a lot of the same muscles like
explosive core work where
you're using your core muscles to kind
of pull yourself off the floor into the
air that stuff's always really good
um i also like kick through burpees as
well which are quite uh advanced
exercise and yeah all that type of stuff
i really like doing
i made a whole video explaining the
differences between plyometrics and
ballistic exercises
rest times and things but that doesn't
really matter this is the said principle
if you want to move quickly then you
need to train quickly you need
fast intent this will improve rate of
force development altering the rate
coding
such that you learn to recruit the most
powerful motor units immediately
here we're using compensatory
acceleration to generate more force than
is needed to move the weight slowly
so that when you want it it's there this
also helps us to improve strength to
weight ratio
in other words we're not just strong but
strong for our size
this is important as it allows us to
move quickly and remain agile
if you're extremely strong but you can't
do a pull-up or jump more than a few
inches off the floor
it might be time to lighten the load and
focus on bar speed instead
so what would you say then it is is like
a really
well spent time in the gym for like a
you know basketball player or someone
like
what do you guys think conditioning yeah
or what like
um just endurance and the right type of
conditioning
yeah the right type of cardio if we want
to train for martial arts then we need
to focus on strength endurance as much
as raw power
being massively strong is of no use if
you tire out after a single punch
or if you get out of breath climbing the
stairs mma fights and definitely dragon
ball fights
go on for some time so you need to focus
on strength endurance
that means conditioning strength
endurance is more important in the real
world too
it's far more useful to be able to carry
something a distance than it is to pick
up something really heavy
just once it's also far more important
than sports
the military favor strength endurance
over max strength and again
our explosive calisthenics functional
movements and weighted clothing
all lend themselves perfectly to this
kind of training the aim is to be as
explosive as possible
through long sets and repeated bouts
this also reshapes your body like
nothing else
remember bodybuilders use high reps
because it provides metabolic buildup
triggering hypertrophy and as this
becomes a type of cardio
you'll simultaneously be melting away
fat there's another reason why big
muscles may appear
to slow a fighter down tension in the
case of a punch the biceps and lats are
pulling the fister back in
if you haven't practiced punching you'll
struggle to turn off these muscles
while you deliver the blow relaxing the
muscles that are working in an
antagonistic fashion
so when you punch your triceps your
shoulders
your pecs are pushing forwards your
bicep and your lats
pulling back but what happens if you're
not
used to this movement pattern if you
haven't trained it is that they're going
to
fight against one another the antagonist
muscles are slowing down
that movement a pro athlete on the other
hand enjoys something called reciprocal
inhibition meaning that as the necessary
muscles contract the others relax
and that's why you'll often hear
metaphors like whipping a towel or
throwing a ball it's a similar sort of
pattern where you'll have
you have to try and be relaxed until the
moment of impact
we actually see this in dragon ball
super when whis tells vegeta that he
needs to relax while fighting
it's also implied that this is one of
the reasons ultra instinct is so
effective for goku
martial artists know this intuitively
but it was also confirmed by research
conducted on ufc
fighters by dr stuart mcgill he found a
double pulse occurred in the fighters
during a punch an initial contraction to
generate the strike
and a second pulse to create stiffness
in the entire body on impact
in tai chi the aim is to move using the
minimal amount of tension
and as much relaxation as possible so in
the opening move of the first form
you raise your arms like this and then
lower them
and as you do that you need to be
consciously aware of every muscle in
your body
and trying to relax anything that isn't
absolutely
crucial
for the movement it's a long time since
i did any tai chi say this
is probably awful but that's something
very different from what most athletes
what most even martial artists practice
on a regular basis
certainly most strength athletes but it
gives you that control to not only
contract the muscle be powerful when you
need to but also to relax the movement
the muscle and to be whip-like and
water-like when you need to this is
difficult due to the irradiation effect
tension that we naturally carry and more
however learning to relax the muscle is
a technique that can develop huge power
and martial artists aren't the only ones
who have discovered this old-time
strongmen like maxic
likewise believe this technique could
provide huge strength gains
so maybe try practicing some tai chi
check out my video on quasi isometrics
and try performing some passive yielding
isometrics
hard style kettlebell training can also
teach this technique and of course
just be mindful of the tension you're
carrying during your training
tai chi practitioners speak about
feeling the flow of energy through the
body
and this makes sense in this context i
actually have a theory that visualizing
the flow of chi around the body
is a tool used for tapping into the mind
muscle connection
it helps to visualize the muscle and
thereby contract or loosen it as
necessary
sadly i don't think you'll be able to
fire that chi out of your hands like a
kamehameha or genki dharma
anytime soon genki actually refers to
vitality
check out some shaolin monks though if
you want to see the kinds of things that
are possible
through this kind of focused will and
finally what about all those chores that
goku and krillin did for master roshi
what about chasing king kai's monkey
bubbles or climbing coron tower
well actually this type of training is
ideal for building more adaptable
strength
by incorporating a cognitive component
by introducing unexpected variables
and by mixing things up these kinds of
training challenges
can actually help to build more robust
mental models bruce lee said to fear the
man who practiced a single kick a
thousand times
that's certainly true if you want the
sharpest most efficient technique
possible
but because real life is unpredictable
and non-linear you should eventually
introduce
more unpredictability and variety into
your training this way
you can apply those skills in a wider
variety of situations
your body is now prepared for the
changes in gradient speed and momentum
it's also awesome and fun and if dragon
ball teaches us anything it's that
training
should be awesome and fun
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did please
leave a like and share around
i'll be returning to this topic again in
future so subscribe and hit the
notification bell if you want more like
this
got some cool stuff from grant on the
way too comment down below and let me
know how dragon ball influenced your own
training
and guys if you want much more advice on
training for martial arts specifically
then be sure to check out grant's own
channel i'll put the link to that in the
description down below
he's an absolute font of knowledge
you've seen how talented he is
and he gives a lot of that information
away completely free so i absolutely
recommend going and checking out that
stuff you should also check out jc
santana and the institute of human
performance
he trained mma fighters and he's really
inspired my own training lately
and i'll also be sharing some more
conversations that we've been having on
different platforms
very soon if you're interested in
training to improve your performance
then you could check out my book
functional training and beyond available
on amazon
and from all good bookstores to learn
more alternatively you could check out
super functional training
that's a huge pdf containing a full
training program and ebook with lots of
extras
this program trains everything from
strength and speed to focus mobility and
more
there's a discount on right now during
the pandemic and you can find the link
in the description down below
either way thanks so much for watching
this one guys i really appreciate it
and i'll see you next time bye for now